[موسيقى]
الفن بالمغرب العربي والفن خدمي جمالي
يعني موجود بكل مكان مو مؤطر بلوحه وهي
احلى الحلو بقصيره لانه اللوحه خرجت
للشارع صحيح هي المتلقي بده يروح يشوفها
بالمتحف لا المتحف بالشارع وصار الانسان
هو
بلاش شعور يعيش الجمال وبالله شعور ينمو
عنده تذوق البصري
انت الان في اصيله خالد
وصلت الى اصيله برحلاتك يعني وتحمل حروفك
ايضا وهذه المدينه ايضا لها سحر خاص هذا
السحر يجذب الفنانين ويجذب الممسوسين
باللغه
وبالجمال ماذا قالت لك وماذا قلت لها
ان اذكر اول
اول فكره او اول مجيء لاصيله يعني سالني
سير بن عيسى هاتفيا انه نحب ندعيك لاصيله
فاستعرضت استعاره عن ابن عبد ربه قلت له
اني يعني اسعى الى اصيله مشيا حتى ان اردت
لانه فعلا كان في شوق من زمان اعرف واقرا
عن اصيله واعرف كم هي ملهمه من فنانينها
ومن زائريها ويعني تمثل بالنسبه الي
الكثير اصيله واجي باستمرار وكل مره تضيف
بعد اخر لان هذه المره جئت بالخريف لاول
مره قبل ناتي بموسم الصيف موسم الصيف
غليان ناس عصف بكل المستويات بالخريف
كانه اخذ خلوه بالمدينه فهذه الخلوه
بالنسبه لي مهمه جدا فشفت هذا الشيء يعني
اعطاني هيك اعطاني نوع من الهدوء والسكينه
لكن هذا الهدوء
لم يتمثل باللوحه تمثل بعصف كبير بالعمل
الفني